it is American Education week CCSD is  celebrating students and staff this  morning schools around the valley took  part in Ruby Bridges walk to school day  it honors civil rights icon Ruby Bridges  she became one of the first black  children to integrate into an all-white  School in New Orleans staff from Gordon  McCaw Elementary talked about what they  hope students learn from today's event  ship leadership skills learning how to  collaborate work together  diversity welcome each other love each  other and walk as a group to be  successful events are lined up all week  to celebrate and highlight the hard work  of students and staff